hey there's going on welcome to Brooklyn
New York
it's not the greatest place in the world
but it's where we live for now I'm
planning on moving to say more in I'm
just used to home which is New York but
I'm definitely want to move back out to
the Caribbean islands which is my you
know real poem so nothing against
America but I'm just used to like the
natural food the natural water a natural
air everything is cleaning it down there
the waters actually blue it's not green
okay no offense Orchard Beach what it is
and yeah you don't have grocery stores
and stuff like there's open 24 hours but
the crime is down so it's not that bad
probably the only thing good in the hood
vitamin water where's our endorsement
deal we can push you guys like 10 years
now
nah ngo5 ruled on to the bone you sound
annoyed I owe you spit up na video games
yeah the good news is in the hood as
long as you're cool with the people
nobody bothers you so and they can tell
whether or not you're from the hood or
not like I'm endangering the cameraman
everybody but as long as you with me his
ID we understand the environment so we
know the do's and don'ts it's like you
get this heightened sense of how to
avoid the danger and stay away from
certain people and we just do our thing
here we just live here and we don't hang
out here in Brooklyn we want to hang out
we go into Manhattan blah blah blah
where we live in the ghetto we're not a
part of it
that's funny the world's greatest gamer
sauce is in this apartment
stupid Google come election will attract
women let's run this unit I am elected
by it's Saturday so we can usually have
all members of the umpire come over and
I pretty much run sessions Marvel Street
Fighter I remember these guys in like
before like 15 now these guys is like in
their late 20s and stuff like that and
they're all world champions little
frustration is that again no I'm gonna
push me if I'm push they actually I'm
not I'm not I'm not mad I'm just trying
to figure it out players like me I came
from Jersey so this is a lot further for
me but when I come down here this is
what we do we are we we play we I guess
do a think tank we try to figure out the
best way to be the best at the games
that we play so with that in mind we
require each other it's like we couldn't
do it on our own
hi that chart goes to my best friend Ron
sixteen years ago I didn't know someone
can play so many games and beat so many
games in the house was also a lot of
other players like Claymore they all
were really good at different types of
games before I met rifles I just didn't
know that somebody could own over a
thousand games physical games this was
before like a lot of these systems this
is like during SNES genesis 64 era the
most documented tournament wins for a
gaming team is 1111 achieved by my
Acadie members of team apps competed and
live gaming tournaments online
competitions and world record attempts
and we've been doing this since 2003 how
many people can actually say their
organization has over 20-something
players and Guinness Book of World
Record only one
you can imagine I was like seven eight
years old and I was running around the
Bronx with my friends going to our key
to arcade playing the latest games
trying to get high scores and then you
know I got older I got married and my
wife was like what are you going to do
this forever
and I was like pretty much and she was
like well I've got to put food on the
table
so that's when I incorporated it into a
business
a good 13 years of my life was here in
America trying to make a life for me and
my wife
at the time gaming wasn't exploding like
how it is now so she couldn't see the
light at the end of the tunnel
I don't hate her or anything like that I
understand she wanted to make sure she
secured a life for herself make sure she
had a family so she couldn't take that
ride with me
in Jamaica they tell you when you're
growing up like in America the roads are
paved in gold one time I found a hundred
dollar bill in my life walking and
anyone who's watching this I'm sure you
found a 20 a 10 or 100 dollar bill on
the street in Jamaica that's not
possible
in Jamaica everyone watches their money
there is no coins to be found in the
street no nothing so for my parents a
cane in New York
well my father first came to this
country with my mother
Gary separated my mother went back to
Jamaica and my father was left here with
me and my two brothers
he drove a taxi 18 hours a day
took up a job at the Wayne Reedy work
from inventory to manager to executive
manager to junior or senior executive
and he did that for like 16 years
14-hour shifts until his entire body
broke down on him I failed it and now
you can't work anymore everybody starts
at the ground level the suckers are
always at the bottom and they stay at
the bottom
it's like playing a video game but you
never want to get off level one but then
you always aspire to beat the game you
can't beat the game if you stay on level
one
right now
also chicken wing
so we're switching things up yes from
awesomeness to awesome yes yes we are
are you a gamer are you a gamer
world-renown yeah me do it let me do it
let me do it try for yes that's what he
goes by No
like Zelda where link starts out in
Kokura forks he has no idea what's going
on in the world when you leave your
local area you find out the dangers that
are there and the different cultures
that you need when you journey to
different towns there's no different
from that when you join it to a
different state you meet the different
type of gamers there the different
levels of competition gaming has
literally become my life a lot of people
would say grow up and get a life and I'm
like I am grown and this is my life what
do you want me to do so you know uh some
people look down at it but they don't
understand you know they don't know
anything about me what I've been through
where I came from when things got hard I
stayed at in the run so you know I stick
by you know what you know I'm about and
what I grew up on video games that's my
life this is what I live
we lost our mother
they're going to bury her this weekend
I'm trying to raise money to get a plane
ticket to go out there to be with my
family so that we can hold a funeral
together as a family and barrier as a
family she would ask me what's going on
in my life and I would tell her about
what I'm doing in gaming how long have
you been doing this how come you're not
successful yet how come you're not
making money
before my mother passed she spoke with
the family about what is everybody gonna
do went on she's gone they were talking
about me and it was like Triforce has
been doing this Empire Acadia thing for
10 years and I really haven't been
profitable I have no kids I'm single and
you know I'm 34 now next month I want to
be 35 but my mother told them Triforce
is in the Guinness Book of World Records
so it may be proud and the thing that
makes that statement so important to me
isn't the fact that I made her proud but
the fact that she recognizes me as
Triforce
my mother worked two charity
organizations one in America and one in
Jamaica so she has always been a
contributor to society on a constructive
and productive level to help other
people so I try to model my organization
after the very same things that she did
like through gaming
the life that God gives us on this
planet is for us to enjoy all the
different experiences that we come
across no other experience in life is
greater than the family but again I am
God I am God
ha ha ha
no matter how rich you are no matter how
successful you are no matter what
adventures you go through in life you
have to go home when you go home your
family is at home
video games is like a framework to life
it's like a guide you start off your
quest you have a quest objective rescue
the princess in order to do that you
need to level up which requires money
you're going to have some obstacles in
your way up to the future adversaries
face the last boss you beat the last
boss and then rescue the princess and
you live happily ever after that sounds
like life to me
Triforce Johnson and Empire Arcadia is
recognized as having the most documented
tournament wins for a gaming team with
that record standing up 2,000 and was
achieved by Empire Arcadia as of May 14
2015 eSports now is big with the music
bigger than movies and bigger than
normal athletic sports so long live
eSports and long live Empire Arcadia
Thank You Alton
isn't this your birthday that's my
birthday May 14th Chris I'm a little old
I wasn't born on 2015 okay